[Music]
people are understanding that robot
systems don't exist in a vacuum that our
robots regardless of what they do are
going to have to interact with humans at
the end of the day these advances that
we're seeing in computer vision where
we're able to very very rapidly detect
people's facial expressions or people's
body posture through things like open
pose have enabled our systems to get the
data that they need in order to
interpret human social behavior and then
on the human robot interaction side all
of these you know many studies coming
out that are trying to understand how
people interact with robots in various
ways and how robots can interpret human
behavior and use their own social
behavior to improve the interactions
between human and robots and so on the
production and understanding side the
human robot interaction research is
going to play a big part my vision for
the future is that technology has a
positive impact we have to answer
questions about how our technology could
be used for good and could be used for
bad and how we can aim our technological
advances toward positive impact in the
world I think this really means that we
need to be multidisciplinary need to
pull in lawyers and policy makers and
people from social sciences and we also
need to pull in people from technology
who understand the capabilities of these
systems and understand what's even
possible to talk about in in terms of
the societal impact
so thanks to Ella for a wonderful talk
and Tom for those great questions to
help explore some of these issues in
more detail we're going to shift now
into the second session of the
conference focused on trust so I think
it's very easy for people to focus on
the trust that we might or might not
have in the technologies but one of the
important questions is to really go
beyond that and to think about the trust
that we might have and those who develop
the technology or those who are
deploying and using the technology or
those who regulate and write the laws
about the technology or even more how
technology might change the
relationships of trust that we have with
one another so how can the development
of a new technology change our human
human interactions including those that
are grounded in this really fundamental
notion of trust so we're gonna be
exploring that over the next hour and a
half and through it through a variety of
formats and we're going to start with a
talk by one of our K&L gates
presidential fellows Abigail Marsh
Abigail was a double major in computer
science and mathematics at Oberlin
College in Ohio and is now a PhD student
in the societal computing program here
in the computer science department her
work really is focused on a notion of
usable privacy the idea of how do we
have privacy that is helping us achieve
the ends that we want and in particular
how that arises with adolescents and
teenagers so without further ado thank
you so much and thank you David for the
welcome that includes my undergraduate
education I really appreciate that um so
the funny thing about being a privacy
researcher is that when you see a news
story about some way that technology or
a tech company has violated trust you
actually see through that and you say oh
this is a privacy violation that these
people are really outraged about yes we
frame it in the public as trust but for
example you look at Cambridge analytic
as scandal recently Facebook has
multiple so let's focus on Cambridge and
you see that
what's really being talked about here is
the idea that Facebook would allow
outside parties to collect information
about people who did not consent to it
so they thought that information was
private they thought it was contained
within their social networks and
Facebook servers and they had no idea
that somebody outside of Facebook could
actually be harvesting it and using it
for unstated purposes that the user did
not get to consent to right and you also
see other examples of things like this
we talked a lot about algorithmic bias
and one way that privacy researchers
study algorithmic bias is through
behavioral advertising online behavioral
advertising where the fundamental
question is often how did this website
this advertising network which I've
never directly interacted with on my own
get this information about me to be able
to profile me and sell me these ads
which may be biased in some way as a
woman maybe I'm more likely to see
pregnancy-related ads or mother related
ads and I didn't even know that the
advertising network knew my gender to
begin with right so these trust
violations are actually privacy
violations in my own work I decided to
say privacy is is a fantastic area of
research for technologists but so far
it's really been focused on self
sufficient adults people in their 20s or
30s or 40s or 50s and I'm sorry for
those of you who've been left out of
that but that is the range it's
generally considered worth studying in a
lot of privacy research and there aren't
a lot of people who have focused on the
fact that people outside of that
relatively narrow range of human
experience are interacting with
technology sharing their information
with these websites and with the
software and therefore can experience
privacy violations as well many of you
in this room will have been parents or
if you are parents at the very least you
were child at one point and you probably
recognize that the teenage years are
very difficult years it's hard to raise
a teenager especially
in today's era where teens are spending
a lot of time online or spending time
with their devices right and so as a
parent it's natural to want some sort of
assistance some sort of help and there
are a lot of software aids that promise
to parents oh we'll take care of making
sure that your child stays out of bad
websites or only uses appropriate
language or something like that which
seems like a miracle fix right you can't
be watching your child's phone use over
their shoulder every second of the day
so great install a software and do that
and these software's offer a lot of
benefits especially for younger children
maybe we agree that five-year-old
shouldn't have access to pornography
right so it's easy to hit just block all
porn and your five-year-old can use your
iPad without any danger of a weird
Google result sort of like prompting
that birds-and-the-bees discussion a
little too early but it runs into a lot
of issues when we talk about teens and
preteens who are doing a lot of their
socialization and identity formation
online right they're talking to their
friends they're figuring out who they
are and some of that might mean
exploring concepts and topics that are
occasionally inappropriate and in
general might be inappropriate but are
necessary and important in certain
contexts right and there's a lot of
trust violations that these softwares
can pose as a child why would I want a
software like this on my phone how do I
know it's going to respect my autonomy
it's essentially designed to snitch on
everything I've ever done wrong and send
an alert directly to my parent at the
moment of violation that like hey
something is going wrong here you should
go punish your child right and even if
we don't consider the child's feelings
there's still the parents concerns about
trust right these software's can collect
a lot of information about what the kid
is doing with their phone some of them
suggest collecting every text message
the contents of every text message that
your child sends or every social media
message right
that means text and
and pictures I don't necessarily want a
company to have that data about me or
about my child and these are concerns
that parents have to face when they
choose to install a software like this
on their child's device right we don't
like when Google or Facebook has this
information but we're supposed to be ok
with it when a much smaller less
accountable company does and finally
there are questions of algorithmic
biases a lot of these softwares use ml
to do something like predictive blocking
of content within webpages but how do I
know as a parent that this opaque
algorithm is respecting my parenting
wishes is blocking what it should be and
is not blocking what it shouldn't be so
there are a lot of trust issues here
with technology that involve people
other than than self sufficient sort of
middle range adults who are willingly
interacting with the the software in
question and we need to continue to ask
questions about who is using this and
who is being affected so we make sure to
capture the experiences and the privacy
needs of everybody in our society thank
you so much happy really wonderful and
it's always wonderful to see the amazing
research that's being done by the
students here that it isn't simply
faculty it's the graduate students it's
the undergraduates it's the many people
around this community all engaged in
asking these kinds of questions so for
then for the next part of the session
we're gonna try something a little bit
different and and hopefully it will go
smoothly so we're going to ask three of
our distinguished guests to join us up
here and perhaps turn the tables a
little bit have them not simply be
speakers but also be moderators so what
we're calling I'm calling it a long
conversation and the idea is that we
will sequentially interview one another
for a brief period of time about five
minutes at which point there will be a
very discreet chime two-letter ooh and
know that we're going to move on in the
next
part of the interview will happen and
then we'll we'll have a much broader
conversation among the four of us around
issues of trust so I'm delighted to
invite up three people
Kirsten vineyard is an expert in
international security policy with over
20 years of experience at the United
Nations she's currently the deputy
director and chief of operations at the
UN Institute for disarmament research
unity R and since 2013 she's led you
Nadir's work on the weaponization of
increasingly autonomous technologies
that sentence came out wrong she's led
the work on trying to understand the
impacts and how we might address the
weaponization she has not been
weaponizing technology herself she also
served as a consultant to four of the
five UN groups of governmental experts
on cyber security Moshe Vardy is the
George Distinguished Service professor
in computational engineering and
director of the Ken Kennedy Institute
for information technology at Rice
University he's a world leader on
automated reasoning and is the author
and co-author of over 500 papers as well
as two books he's received numerous
awards and honorary degrees and is a
member of five different national
academies including the US National
Academy of Engineering and the US
National Academy of Sciences finally
Manuela Veloso is the Herbert a Simon
University professor and head of the
machine learning department here at
Carnegie Mellon University she's
transformed our understanding of social
and collaborative robotics and has also
authored over 500 papers
she was named the Einstein chair
professor by the Chinese Academy of
Sciences in 2012 is a fellow of the
American Association for the Advancement
of science as well as the I Triple E and
triple AI and is a former president of
the triple AI so Kirsten Moshe and
Manuela if you could join me up here on
stage
[Applause]
so start with Kirsten in your view what
is the most important or challenging
aspect for trust in AI and robotic
technologies including their development
and use a nice simple question with only
one answer the only one answer only a
possible all right well I'm coming to
this conversation from an international
security and arms control perspective so
I guess you won't be surprised when I
say that I find the implications of the
weaponization of these technologies to
be a particularly important topic issues
surrounding transparency validation and
verification of algorithmic systems are
among the most important open questions
in AI today and they are equally
important from an arms control
perspective when we start considering
the implications of increasing autonomy
in weapons systems so I'm going to give
you three examples of how Trust in these
systems is challenged by developments in
AI so first we have challenges for
testing and verification of weapons
systems and it's probably pretty obvious
but you really want to trust your weapon
systems these are technologies that are
intentionally designed to do harm right
unlike many of the technologies that we
design and because of that as operators
of these systems you have a moral and
legal responsibilities probably at a
higher level as then you would have as
an operator of a different type of
technology that's not designed to cause
harm and one of the reasons that we
trust our weapon systems is because we
rigorously test them before deployment
and this isn't an aspiration it's
actually a legal requirement under
article 36 of the Additional Protocol
one to the Geneva Conventions so
increasing autonomy and weapon systems
challenges testing I'm due in large part
to issues of predictability and it's
further complicated
the case of learning systems where the
system continues to learn post
deployment and then verification which
is a very important concept in arms
control we use it as a stability
mechanism verification so how could
international regulation of military
applications of AI be verified
verification usually involves counting
physical objects right so intangible
capabilities don't really work that way
and it's difficult to imagine that
states or even corporations would be
willing to permit inspection of their
code or algorithms and it's questionable
that even inspection would even be
useful at because determining whether or
not an algorithm is quote-unquote
militarized is probably near impossible
right because it's a dual use sort of
situation second example would be trust
by the user so machine learning systems
behave sometimes behave unexpectedly or
in unanticipated ways and in many cases
having AI helped us solve problems in
previously unimaginative AI but as we
become accustomed to AI enabled objects
behaving in surprising ways we're gonna
have one less metric to determine
whether a weapon system is behaving in a
way other than the way the operator
intended so that could be due to
internal error or it could be due to
malicious intervention within the system
and that's going to diminish the
operators ability to intervene or
exercise control and as military systems
become increasingly autonomous and
concurrently humans become decreasingly
present in their operation and oversight
there's a risk that humans no longer
serve as the redundant safety feature
which they currently serve in many
weapons systems I mean I think we're all
we've all know about the many nuclear
near misses that have been avoided
because a human operator followed their
instincts rather than what the
technology was telling them was
happening so if a human is no longer
capable of intervening
oh my can they finish up that Center
you've certainly finished the center all
right if they're no longer capable of
intervening due to speed or in your
ability to understand the system or
perhaps even worse we've left the human
on the loop marginally just in order to
serve as a scapegoat for technologic
technology's possible failings or
shortcomings and that's problematic so
those are two examples and maybe y'all
get a chance to tell your third I'm sure
there will be opportunities so good to
see much in your view what is the most
important or challenging aspect for
trust in AI robotic technologies
including in their development in use so
I think it's important to recognize that
we have any situation right now that we
have I would say trust crisis and and I
want to read quotes from two recent
articles appear in the Boston in fact in
the world journal just peggy noonan last
october article somehow talked about the
gun issue and she tried to explain why
people buy guns and argument I think is
very weak but it doesn't matter for the
purpose of this discussion and she
writes because all of the personal and
financial information got hacked in the
latest breach because the country
because our countries really over loads
are in Silicon Valley and appeared to be
moral Martians who operate on some will
new postmodern ethical wavelengths I
guess with financial planning for
immortality and there will be the ones
programming the robots that will soon
take all the jobs January 2 of this year
Niall Ferguson most alarming was the
morphing of cyberspace into Siberia not
to mention the cyber caliphates a dark
and lawless realm were malevolent actors
ranging from Russian trolls
- PO isis twitter users could work with
impurity to subvert the institutional
foundation of democracy if this does not
reflect a crisis in trust i don't know
what is so if we won't talk about trust
we have to start making what does trust
mean so I kind of tried to reflect a
little bit on my own personal experience
in in my military service in there in
the Israeli Defense Forces I went to
power - ting training and you jump from
a height of about 1400 feet which is a
rather terrifying experience I mean you
you you're back brain tells you you're
going to die because you are falling off
of the cliff and you have to trust the
parachute and you have to trust the
parachute folder that folder it properly
so trust means vulnerability you need
trust when you have a sense of danger
and you're trusting something or someone
to help you face this danger and so
obviously if we have a crisis of trust
it means you're all feeling very
vulnerable and do we trust the
technology that is now providing us so I
think when you come to cyber security
there's no cyber security there cyber
insecurity it's a colossal failure of us
is a computing discipline as well as
they as they I think is a political
institution around us that we have not
set up better standard for cyber
security and now we are talking about do
we trust the day the decisions the
machine will make and we heard a lot
about equity and biases and transparency
and I have heard very little discussion
should we delegate this decision to
machines you know we are somehow as if
we are living in a in a deterministic
universe in which it's just determined
the machines will make these human
decisions you know now it's just
deciding you know whether you'll get
power or not whether we will separate a
child from their from their family when
is it going to be sighted whom are you
going to who's going to be your mate you
know will
we already heard algorithmic why bother
was tinder you know we'll let the
Machine decide whom you should you
should go out with and so and the
reality is that people don't like to
talk so much here is that our life are
now with technology is be run by
incredibly large and powerful
corporations total equity of the five
tech companies over three trillion
dollars and one of the things we've
helped before there's no ethics when it
comes to corporations if it's if it's
legal they can do it and it makes money
they will do it we seem to be on this
one is quite a lot right new view what
is the most important or challenging
aspect for trust in iron robotic
technology including little development
and news so I have a more engineering
view of this trust question and more
kind of like I've been quite questioning
how can we do it better at really the
development level so we all want to
trust these machines but eventually we
have to interact with our PhD students
with our students to do PhD thesis to
advance the science of artificial
intelligence and robotics so how is my
dialogue with those students how is my
line of research how is like the steps
that we take to advance our science
going to be different because in fact we
care about trust
so my few remarks are really bringing
you down to not the army not the weapons
but to the moment in which you face a
computer and you have to type if these
than that and you have to program these
machines and you have to help build
programs for which eventually there will
be a change in society so
along those lines for me this question
of trust has to do with the fact that
our AI machinery our machine learning
our robotics machinery has been more of
a problem solver what's the shortest
path and we generate a solution but the
way that we actually function when
writing code when writing programs in
writing algorithms is that we don't have
the challenge of justifying or
explaining why did you say this was a
bottle why do you classify this as a
chair so the explanation part has been
what's present in the old days I mean
and it has been always kind of
underlying their research we even have
teasers on explanation based learning
when we have theses on all sorts of like
analogy trying to come up with like the
similarity between two problems and
justify that resemblance to make
adaptations so but it's not as present
now in terms of actually solving big
problems and still also being able to
justify if needed and have our
algorithms generate such justifications
so my research and my understanding of
trust leads me to for example have our
autonomous robots who actually navigate
in our environments arrive to our office
and be able to answer in language and
not in whatever language they use
internally of numbers and probability
and all sorts of like functions in
language why are you late and why did
you take that route and what are you
going to do next so I believe that trust
comes from the interaction with the
device with the machine and eventually
that machine needs to be able to be
queried needs to be able to be
questioned about the decisions that
actually they made towards solving
whatever problem we asked them to solve
so in that sense for me Trust has to do
a lot with transparency
with explanation with counterfactuals
can we ask a machine what if you had
done something different can these
machine process these type of questions
and be more explicit about whatever
algorithm they are running and what the
solution would be all those scenarios so
transparency and explanation I think are
part of the internals of AI machines
that may enable us to build more trust
in what they do thanks to all three of
you really got got some wonderful issues
out on the table and so I actually would
like to start Manuela if it's okay with
you with what you were just talking
about in terms of the transparency and
explain ability and I think one question
that comes up when we think about the
trust is perhaps transparency for whom
or explain ability for whom because of
course something that would be
understandable or explainable to a PhD
graduate student might be very different
from somebody on the street who doesn't
know as much about the technology so how
do we think about these different
audiences for explain ability it's a
very good question not only the
different audiences but also different
moments in time even for someone that
interacts with the robot or with the
agent many times you don't want to
produce the same explanation today that
you produced yesterday or it's otherwise
it's just you are telling me the same
thing and that didn't help me so we
actually introduced this concept of a
space of explanations a space of
verbalization together with one of my
students eyes of raj and vittorio
pereira and stephanie Rosenthal and we
have been working on this issue about
the the multiple facets of explanations
and in fact trust these levels of
Trustees levels of transparency these
level of explanation are not a single
entity like you say a single kind of
like concept and we have done some
machine learning on crowdsourcing people
and trying to understand if someone asks
what what exactly do you happen by the
elevator
that that exactly by the hell by the
elevator would be something that would
require a much more narrow explanation
as if someone would ask where you come
from and that's like a language that
requires a different explanation of the
mobility of the machine then what
happened by the elevator so we did a lot
of research and we do as we speak a lot
of research on trying to understand a
question from a human what exactly means
in terms of an explanation required from
the machine so it seems to me that in a
lot of cases this kind of explain
ability if we had it would be able to to
help some with one of the issues that
you raised Kirsten which was about the
difficulty of verification in rapidly
changing environments where the system
might be deployed somewhere whether on
the battlefield or in the international
context where perhaps it hasn't been
used before so how do we verify that
it's going to work there do you think
that explain ability would be something
that could provide a guide as we think
about sort of how to how we can build
trust in as you said some of these
technologies that can can even have
lethal impacts well used a great word
transparency and that's something that
we talk again a lot about in arms
control as a stabilizing element so yes
I think explain ability is
extraordinarily important at the same
time it circles back to that question of
for who are we explaining to and and
when because when we're talking about
lethal systems sometimes post facto
explain ability it's good to be able to
unpack that right
afterwards if something went wrong but
it's it's a bit late right so explain
ability is very important but I think we
should be focusing more on on thinking
about how do we ensure confidence in the
systems whether they are weapon systems
or other systems before we deploy them
and so explained ability I think is a
much
you're part of the process then actually
post-deployment
I mean it's still necessary and it's
part of that very important human
machine interface that's going to be
critical in all of our AI embedded
systems but explain ability with weapon
systems because of the risk being so
high it's I think it's a bit of a
unicorn
we need it we need it a lot sooner
certainly as you said the post factor
that is small comfort if after the fact
you know why that happened it seems that
in many ways that connects to some of
things you were raised in Moshe in terms
of the need to be able to trust the
developers themselves we can trust men
well as graduate students we can trust
Manuela but as we've been hearing about
in various times throughout this
conference there are companies who are
doing things that perhaps are not out of
an effort to produce technology that
will help people as opposed to helping
the bottom line so could we extend for
example this notion of explained ability
to the developers they have to explain
why they did what they did or what
solutions do you think we might pour
paths might we be able to go down to
improve trust and developers well I
think we have to go back to the
questions why do we need trust and when
it trusts because we feel vulnerable ok
and this is true this is basically human
fear if you go if you're a child I
remember being being a child and walking
in darkness why are you afraid when it's
dark well because you don't know what
are the threats out there right I mean
so you turn the light on and okay it's
nothing to worry about and so human
beings are very vulnerable we are very
fragile okay and so all if you think
about all what all these things were
talking about transparency and explained
ability are all essentially a way to
assuage us that we don't need to be
afraid so this is really we need to go
back is the issue in some sense it's not
so much about trust the issue is about
vulnerability and fear and unfortunately
what we've been learning in the more you
learn that you feel rational really you
know just because you're paranoid it
doesn't mean the summer is not trying to
kill you
and what I've been learning recently
there are people out there for us know
maybe not to kill
but to manipulate us and this if you
think about this issue be money
manipulated it goes back to our sense of
self and vulnerability and we feel
violated when we realize we've been
manipulated and so maybe it's not a
threat for life but it is still some
kind of a threat to our own notion of
self and self determinacy and so we
start have to figure out I mean the
issue first of all is not how to somehow
make us feel safe here first of all they
have to be real safety then we deal with
the psychological factor okay right now
unfolding we are missing the regulatory
framework it will make this
technological world really safe and
that's why we are fredericks
that's why we have no trust in the
system so we have to go beyond just
focusing on the trust assume that it's a
it's a safe world and your feeling of
fearfulness are not justified right now
I have to say I think they are justified
so we have to go beyond the trust issue
we have to remove the threat first and
then we have to deal how do we make sure
that people really trust that this is a
safe environment so Manuela would you
you want to switch to becoming a social
scientist and policy maker to remove
some of these threats I'm going to wave
my hands but so I actually tend to
disagree with this so you know besides
the effect of of being safe and afraid
you also want to trust a machine that if
you ask you know find me a flight to
Paris tomorrow or get me a good flight
to Lisbon that actually it does the job
so it's just trusting the fact that the
thing is going to do what you expected
it to do or if you have like a robot
around here that you'd say you know go
to the conference room and guide the
visitor back to my office that that's
the case that the robot does not go to
the kitchen or does not go anywhere else
so or my refrigerator if I put something
in the freezer I expect it to actually
freeze the food so there is something
about technology that
for me the trust is that in some sense
also it does what it's expected to do
and I think that that before the actual
solving my vulnerability there is also
this the need to meet the expectation
meet the specification and in AI we are
still not there because we really don't
have like robust robots that we say go
down this road and don't don't go over
anyone we are still trying to find the
the machinery that matches the
specification and what we would like the
autonomous agent the autonomous robot
the autonomous the AI assistant to do if
I have an a doctor and I have an AI
assistant that I would like to say and
say go and see if you find any case
similar to these on all the images you
have collected all these data from all
over the world
I would like to trust that the thing
that I'm talking with is a Isis that
does in fact go through all the data in
the whole world
and not just two parts of it to actually
answer my question so the what I believe
it's happening what I believe for me
trust is that the task that I will
interact with is AI agent to be
performed is actually done the way I
expected it to be done so that kind of
like matching my expectations when I
interact with the AI agent is where I
believe that I build a trust in the
Machine I want to add one thing though
to the point that these distrusting the
developers do not trust me do not trust
my students and I'll explain why it's
not not trusting but when just one
single thing I'm not going to put my
hands on fire and guarantee that my
robot is not going to hit the wall or
III just have a hard time achieving that
level of assurance and and the reason is
because the world the environment the
people are very complex systems it's
extremely complex
x2 from a research point of view develop
a solution that is trustable for the
complexity of where we want to make our
systems autonomous it's not bad faith
it's not like it's not really intention
it's just that it is too complex it's
just too hard and it's too hard in the
sense that there is a very uncertain
system that you now are supposed to
handle with some kind of like algorithm
so it's like the sandy storm it's like
9/11 it's like all these complex things
that no one was able even within humans
to be able to find a solution for them
they just I mean the world is too
difficult it's too hard on the other
hand are we going to give up on
automating things just because of the
complexity and so what I'm trying to
tell you is like this I believe we have
to accept their AI as humans do will
eventually make mistakes what we might
not want to accept is that it doesn't
improve over time we do we might not
want to himself is the lack of learning
what I'm saying is that any kind of
instance of something that didn't go
well
needs to be more data and needs to be
more input for the AI system in its
dynamics like ela was saying to become
better even whatever a cognitive
assistant you do to a person if it's not
a moving system a dynamic system that
gets better with experience we are not
going to ever be able to I believe
generates some kind of static system
that handles enormous complexity and
just to finish one thought I've been
doing robot soccer for 20 years so
little soccer playing robots that go to
these competitions even after 20 years
there is always something that surprises
us in these games with an opponent robot
soccer there is the the bursary just
shoots and
bounce is often about robots and we say
how come you are supposed to shoot
directly to go not use our robots and
bouncing halls yeah
that's what happened two years ago then
last year another one of these surprises
inevitably even after 20 years can you
imagine that I go to these games and I'm
still surprised how these adversaries
figure out something that I did not
thought about so that puts you in this
kind of learning curve in this kind of
life trying to minimize the errors you
make and not really assuring that there
are no errors
it's just and of course
perfect predictability and Trust you
don't have to have perfect for the
predictability to have trust we could
have for example many of us have trust
in other humans even though humans
surprising each other all the time it's
I think does go to this issue the motion
is saying if we're making ourselves
vulnerable in certain ways and Trust is
relying on somebody else when you're in
that state of vulnerability and I think
it raises all kinds of interesting
questions of course about the weapons
space because is it reason you know
we've got very good reasons to think
they won't be perfect they will make
mistakes of course human soldiers make
mistakes human policymakers make just
make mistakes so when we think about
verification we think about deliberation
about what we as an international
community or a National Defense
organization ought to do how do we think
about the necessity of accidents the
necessity of surprises they're going to
happen is it you know do we do we aspire
to too much if we aspire to we know we
aspire to too much voice fire to
perfection give thoughts about the
relevance of accidents and surprises in
the context of weapons feel free to say
you'd like to actually I wanted to pick
up on something my mother was talking to
you mind please I'm here talking bout
expectations and this is a really
probably quite technologically
sophisticated audience
I mean technologically literate but I
deal with a lot of people who don't have
a lot of technological literacy
and I I think we're had a real
interesting tipping point when it comes
to this issue of trust and technology
right now where a lot of people have
blind trust we have fear but we have
blind trust in technology and recent
events pick one because there's many to
choose from
have I think brought us to a societal
conversation about wait a minute we need
have to go from having blind trust to
having our technologies the developers
of those technologies and the users and
the deployers of those technologies they
need to earn my trust and we're gonna
have to make that tipping point between
blind trust and earning trust and what
are the mechanisms and what are the
tools that we have to earn trust to
verify trust to have reliable systems
predictable systems confidence in our
systems it's not much more interesting
than weapons earning trust and in fact
one of the things that we are working on
now is like to have these robots
actually what we call verifiable answers
so if I ask a robot how long did it take
you to go from the lab to my office and
the robot says you know two minutes and
a half how do we know that number is
right and so what we do is that we
actually have techniques to decompose
that question and to say okay how much
did it take you from going to the lab to
the kitchen and the robot would say a
minute and 10 seconds and now we ask
from the kitchen to my office and if
these adapts to 2.5 30 we 2 2 minutes
and 30 seconds then you trust that the
answer is good so we are doing a lot of
research with vittorio pereira in his
PhD thesis on this kind of like earning
the trust on finding methods to
decompose your questions so that there
if there was a malware or some wrong
answer that you cannot from a
theoretical point of view
randomly combined so much ever so much
malware that eventually things become
consistent so we are trying to earn turn
trust not only by explain ability but by
checking consistency of the answers such
that they actually add up to something
that makes sense and after all they are
computing or they are answering
something that overall makes sense and
it's proved to be right and so that's
something that's very new in our
research I mean we barely have started
this but again this is the question of
like when they give you an answer do you
trust that or not so you transform that
it's like they know if it's giving me
this answer okay then I'm going to trick
it and ask them more questions until I'm
confident that I earned that I mean that
this thing is trustable I'll just put in
a quick plug I think that this is one of
those places where interdisciplinary
work multidisciplinary work becomes
really critical because this idea of
earning trust development of trust
that's that's an area that social
psychologists organizational behavior
theorists have have studied for a long
time so there's a lot of resources that
that can be sort of bootstrapped to
maybe
short-circuit some of these things but
Moshe I'm sorry you know we talk a lot
about trusting technology but the
reality is Trust is mostly a human
relationship so if I'm talking about the
robot it will come out of manual manual
as love and I said trust at all but I
really trust manuela to make best effort
to give me something which is going to
be safe so because I really you know I
most of the time for most people the
technology is kind of a black box so
what does it mean that I trust this
program I have to trust the developer of
this program so we really need to think
about the different actors that are
involved here and to think of trust as a
relationship it's a human relationship
between different actors to a trust
Manuela yes do I trust certain
corporations maybe no do I trust a
developer that I know nothing about in
you know I mean probably it's
the same thing you know when when we
have a we feel safe with people we know
because we have gone to rebuild trust
between them you walk into a place where
you don't know anyone and in certain
areas of the world still a stranger
every stranger is a potential risk and
so so we have to start thinking less
about the technology and more about who
are the sort of characters in this play
and what are the set of trust we can
have between them and one of the sync of
course we know in warfare situation it's
a different situation and we have to see
very differently about trust then we
think in a non-hostile situation but I
think the trust ultimately it's not
relation between human and machine it's
a relationship between humans
well it seems we'll be like humans they
will make decisions they will process
information they will have tons of data
and they will be things you interact
with like you interact with humans so
eventually you may want to also trust
the machinery and not just the humans
will develop the machine I don't
disagree but if I trust my refrigerator
is because I really trust ultimately the
process that led to building this I mean
how does that every filter of my trust
one because it does what it's supposed
to do but I don't think there's anything
nefarious about it that really the goal
is at some point to suddenly surprise me
and give me poison food because you know
I've the people who built I trust them
ultimately so we end up trusting me
trusting machines by by their
predictability if something is
predictably having a certain way which
says okay but also we we intuitively
think about the dose the Actos human
actors involved in this which of course
then raises a whole other set of issues
and complexities around when you have
companies doing this that for good
competitive reasons I'm not going to
disclose how they built the technology
are not gonna how do we get transparency
of those of that sort and I think these
raise an enormous number of questions
and unfortunately I'm getting the red
light that tells us that that our
conversation is coming to a close I
wanted to give you each one
if you want to say something very
quickly sort of in closing I just want
to say one thing I saw recently a very
interesting video in New York then which
people were interviewed on the streets
about these things we kind of mark I
accept all those terms of conditions of
iPhones and Facebook's and all of this
and they were horrible the things we
accept and I was looking at that I mean
I was looking at that and say guess what
it was a lawyer
it was a human who generated that thing
and not an AI system imagine if that
text were generated by a robot or an AI
system which was fooling me into
accepting all sorts of like horrible
things that we accept we never read that
like pages and pages and pages and
whoever generated that was not an AI
system was a human so shame on the
humans in the sense that that's where
like I go back now to what Moshe was
saying but let's educate the humans
let's eventually have the humans make
these things we accept on in terms of
like machinery be trusted
trusted because this Facebook example
yes we didn't accept but how did you
know that in the whole thing that you
signed up for you were not accepting
that these data would go somewhere else
I mean I have no clue you know we just
accept so Humanzee the loop of
technology need to make sure that things
are trusted and humans need to hear make
sure that that is the case I'm sorry for
my cannon but that's really intimidating
the things we accept in these terms and
conditions it's like oh my god what am i
signing for and somehow it's still not
generated by an AI system and I wonder
if it were an AI system generating those
conditions if people would not be all
outraged how Carmen AI system told me to
accept all these conditions I'm telling
you trust in technology rather than
humans
mosha any final thought I I think we
really need to think very hard about
what makes corporations behave
unethically and it's not the people in
them I mean some of the people here from
cooperation as we serve someone I spent
a big part of my life in a corporation
many of conferencing cooperation but
nevertheless there is something our
current economic system that makes
corporations behave legally and
ethically and that means either we need
to change the laws to make more
behaviors illegal or we need to rethink
the incentive system under which they
operate because they are just right now
in this part of our history so immensely
powerful the day behavior has huge
impact on our lives sometimes I think we
get we get caught up in the bright and
shiny and the possibilities and the
potentials of new technologies and we
forget that these technologies serve us
right and so rather than starting always
as a technology centric conversation
which is not only constantly evolving
due to innovation but also quite
alienating for a large part of the
population who doesn't have the
technological sophistication to
participate in some of the more deeper
conversations about it we need to be
having more human centric conversations
about how humans employ technology to to
meet human objectives unfortunately in
my in my field that's human objectives
of conflict and resolving these are the
tools of violence that humans decide to
employ but in other fields whether it's
healthcare education or criminal justice
these are tools that work for us and we
need to can affirm our human values and
our objectives and our desires and what
levels of trust we're going to demand or
what what metrics we're going to use and
then ensure that our deployers and our
developers of technologies meet those
requirements because we're in charge at
least for now nominally so with that
call to action let's thank our
panelists conversations so we're now
going to shift to one last part of our
session which is please leave the
microphone sorry
that we'll get back up there eventually
which is a final spotlight talk by
Professor Anka dragon who is an
assistant professor in electrical
engineering and computer science and UC
Berkeley and a I believe proud at least
an alumna got her PhD from here at
Carnegie Mellon and I think is proud of
that fact I hope and she at Berkeley
runs the interactive autonomy and
collaborative technologies or interact
lab which is really focused on a lot of
these questions about human and human
robot interaction how do we have robots
that actually are able to interact with
humans in ways that can support and
empower both sides which requires doing
research really at the intersections of
robotics machine learning and cognitive
science she's also helped to found the
Berkeley AI Research Lab is a COPI I of
the Center for human compatible AI and
has won multiple early career awards and
were delighted to welcome her about to
Pittsburgh on Kjartan
hi everyone pleasure to be here I am
going to basically agree with everything
that Manuel I said and maybe add one
twist so robots take actions that change
the state of the world and as we've
heard yesterday what the way they choose
the actions that take is usually via
something called a reward function or
objective function so they plan actions
that in expectation maximize cumulative
reward I think when things can go wrong
is when people have mental models of
these robots they do not match up with
reality and so I've been so that for
instance the robot is much less capable
than what the person assumes or it
doesn't take the actions that the person
thinks that the robot will take and so
I've been asked to talk about trust but
what I really want to talk about is not
so much how do we get people to trust
these systems but rather how do we
ensure alignment between the person's
mental model and reality and I think
that there's two complimentary ways to
talk about doing that on the one hand we
can work on the robot side and try to
bring the robot up to match to live up
to our expectations and I would call
that making it trust able or trustworthy
on the other hand we could work on the
human side and bring expectations and
calibrate them right to reality my
background my personal background is
actually in transparency so I don't want
to focus so much on transparency today
but I do want to talk about it for a
couple minutes to just share some
highlights so if we talk about robots
being transparent we have to actually
define what that means and I'm gonna
propose one definition which is what
I've been using I don't think it's the
only definition but the way I've been
thinking about the problem is that
there's some internal state to the robot
like its capability its utility its what
it plans on doing and the human doesn't
get to know that but what the human can
have is some sort of estimate or belief
in what that is and that's the robot
takes actions in the world and these
actions could be physical actions or
explanation
that ends up changing the person's
estimate the person gets to observe that
and adjust their mental model over time
and so I believe that we have an
opportunity here for the robot to not
just maximize the reward that's been
given to achieve the functional task but
also reason about how its actions are
affecting the person's belief and try to
come up with actions that are that
steered the person's belief towards the
correct mental model towards reality and
that to me is what transparency means
and before I move on I just want to give
you a few examples of what that might
look like so here's a robot that is
planning to grab one of these two
bottles the one on the right and it
could do it pretty efficiently but then
it'd be kind of confusing to a person
observing which bottle the robot is
going for so what this robot is figuring
out is that by exaggerating its motion
to the right it can become more clear to
a person observing this motion what it
is that it's about to do it's not the
most efficient way but it's a way that
increases transparency by carefully
selecting actions that take the person's
belief towards the object on the right
could I go that was my thesis at
Carnegie Mellon here we call this
legible motion in the meantime we've
generalized this to a few things
so it utilities for instance here's an
autonomous car sort of placing the
passenger in a situation and showing in
the situation I would cut this other guy
off to convey to the passengers that
look my driving style is a little bit
more on the aggressive side I do believe
we have to calibrate expectations about
capability a lot and so because people
tend to over assume so what we've been
working on is also these robots that
fail and show you the failures and show
them expressively so a robot that says
here's what I'm trying to do and it's
not working and and here's why it's not
working I'm trying to pull on this thing
but it's locked I'm trying to push this
thing but I can't do it I'm trying to
lift this Cup but it's too heavy
and then the final example is one of a
agent that plays pong trained by a deep
reinforcement learning which is all the
rage these days what the agent is doing
here is it's showing us
how it would act in states that it
thinks are critical meaning states where
it thinks it's really important to take
the action that it's about to take so 4
pong this means when the ball is coming
close to you and it's at a high speed
then it's really important to move that
pellet upward down and so the agent is
showing you this so that you can build
this mental model of what it is that it
actually has learned so in a nutshell we
can enable transparency by being careful
about steering the person's belief in
the right direction but after working on
transparency for a bit I became a little
bit disappointed with it because what
transparency is about is calibrating the
person's expectation it's not working on
the person and wouldn't it be nice if we
could do some work on the robot side to
get the robot to live up to the person's
expectation as opposed to just bring the
person's expectations down in a lot of
ways this is what artificial
intelligence is all about
most of the work in AI is about making
robots most trustworthy making robots
actually more capable of doing the thing
typically that means getting robots to
solve this optimization problem how do
you actually optimize the reward that
it's been given to you but what I've
been finding is that even though this is
one modality of increasing capability
there's another thing that can go wrong
which is the reward function itself so
sometimes the reward function does not
actually correspond to what we actually
want the robot to be optimizing for and
it makes sense because the people who
are building these robots were human too
right and more fallible and we don't
always encode the right objectives or
incentives in the robot here's a cute
example of this going wrong this is
video from open AI and this is a boat
racing agent you can't tell that it's
trying to race by looking at it the
reason is that the reward function was
score points in the game and so
while on the top left there you see all
the other agents actually completing the
race what our boat does is it figures
out this loop that it can do and time it
just right so that it collects all these
turbo boosters at the right time and get
a gazillion points okay so you look at
this as designer they're like oh my god
of course this is not what I wanted of
course I wanted you to actually
participate in the race and try to win
but that's not what we specified this is
not a new problem Steve Russell and
Peter Norvig if this example and their
AI book of a vacuum cleaning robot and
the reward function could be the amount
of dust you managed to suck in and that
kind of makes sense because the more
dust that sucks in the cleaner the floor
is but then depending on the hardware
the optimal policy can be suck in a
little bit of dust and then dump it all
out then suck in a little bit more dump
it all back out right and recycle that I
don't think this is necessarily that
specific to AI think this is kind of a
general problem with with technology as
a whole and I think it comes from some
of them we all know about which is that
we were not very good at saying what we
want right we have all these myths and
legends about be careful what you wish
for and the reason it should be careful
is because you might just get it and it
might not be happy with the consequences
like King Midas wishing that everything
it touched turned to gold and I do want
to emphasize that this is not a story
about that is only applicable to Ages
that actually are capable at optimizing
their objectives I struggle with this
every day I do a lot of motion planning
work and motion planning you have to
write down a cost function that trades
off between different things that are
important to the robot this case
distance to the person and distance to
fragile objects and so on what
inevitably happens is you tune the thing
it works over 10 20 different problem
settings different environments and then
you encounter a new environment at some
point that's different enough and the
optimal behavior does not actually
correspond to what you actually wanted
so overall we're not great at specifying
these reward functions and I don't want
to make because this is an AI in ethics
conference I do want to make a little
bit of a theoretical point on
which is that I think that makes it
difficult to encode the ethical
principles that we as humans find so
easy and common sense into these
machines and all us minqi as my helper
to make this point so make your mouse
this is a this is from Fantasia a Mickey
Mouse was charged with getting water
from outside the house into the home and
make he gets tired of this and makes a
robot right uses magic to bring a broom
to life and shows it how to do the test
and Mickey goes to bed and then Mick he
wakes up and he's in a puddle of water
and he realizes that his robot assistant
was a bit overzealous with optimizing
the objective function that he specified
what's interesting here is that Mickey
then goes and you'll see in a second he
goes and tries to stop the broom but
that doesn't work because the broom was
given an objective function and sort of
what make you suggesting is not optimal
and so kind of a best bait very very
basic I'm not sure I'm sure I would even
call it ethical basic principle you
might want to encode right in this
reward function is look you should do
what people say okay so I just want to
point out a theoretical level that
that's not actually that trivial so the
way you might structure this you might
say here's the normal reward function
you should optimize for this except if
the person says do something else right
more reward than doing the something
else but if you set this up to be high
enough not that I'm worried that robots
would actually figure out how to do this
at all but just theoretically I want to
point out that which of what we just did
is we provided an incentive to the robot
to try to get itself in situations where
then people would react and give it
Corrections so that it can then accept
them and cash in on all of that reward
right and similarly if you make it too
low other things happen so it's not
trivial to tune these things right even
for something as basic as do what people
say now I'm not worried about this would
robots today you know perhaps they have
very narrow actions faces so they will
never figure out even if that's the
reward function how
to actually do that here's a robot it
moves from a start to a goal location
it's trying to be efficient it's trying
to optimize for staying away from things
and I it's very easy to get it to do
what I want so if I'm unhappy with how
it's doing the task if for instance I
think that it's keeping the bottle the
the mug too high up what I can do is I
can just go there and push on it and it
will do the thing and I can write a
controller pretty easily maybe an
impedance controller that makes the
robot actually compliant to human touch
the interesting thing for the robot
though and what's hard for a real robot
today it's not so much accepting this
kind of oversight but figuring out what
to do with it afterwards because the
moment I let go right the robot goes
back to optimizing its objective its its
reward function and so the moment I let
go right the robot goes back to the old
way of doing the task and I keep pushing
on it and he keeps going back and I keep
pushing at it and if it keeps going back
to what it thinks is the optimal way of
doing it and can be pretty frustrating
so what real robots I think the more in
a certain near-term problem is that you
shouldn't just be compliant you should
actually try to continually learn from
this oversight that people give you and
try to not make the same mistakes again
and again and again and so what all
these three examples I think teachers is
that the classical AI picture here is
missing something there's no reward
function that's exogenously specify it
doesn't come from the sky instead what
we have is we have people that want
things internally and that's what the
robot should be trying to optimize for
if it's a designer right then the
designer might actually specify a reward
function but chances are because we're
human and because we're fallible that
that's not necessarily gonna match up
perfectly it's not gonna be totally
drawn but it's not gonna match up
perfectly to what people actually what
the designer actually wants internally
and what we do right now is we just take
that for granted we just plug it in and
say this is what we're optimizing for as
if humans are perfect but they're not
and I
the picture that we should really be
reasoning about is this one where you
have a robot the trust actually work
with the person to figure out what it is
that they really want and it's hard
because you know we can't actually
decode what people think internally it's
a really tough tough thing to do but I
think we can make some progress towards
that so let me give you an example of
one thing that we've been thinking about
so we're back to the boat racing game do
you remember the game with the with the
boat racing that was doing the loop so
what was happening there was essentially
the boat had the choice between winning
and getting a lot of points say 20 or
exploiting this kind of loop that it
could do get even more points but not
win and it shows the second version and
the reason it shows the second version
was because there was a designer who
said look you should optimize for score
in the game so the interesting question
is why did the designers say that right
we designers are not totally dumb right
we're not just gonna write down a reward
function and deployed their sent the
robot off them to the world
and hope for the best so the reason was
that the designer actually tested this
robot on some environments and on those
environments optimizing for points got
the boat to actually do the correct
thing so at training time the the
environments that the person actually
looked at were pretty different than
this one test environment the training
time you could actually win with a lot
of points if you had fewer points then
you wouldn't win as much or as many
times or you would lose and so score and
winning were correlated at training time
but they were no longer correlated at
test time and that's what broke things
so that's one of the things that can go
wrong or you have features that no
longer correlate things can go wrong in
many other ways here's another example
say I'm building a robot to drive around
the CMU campus and I know it's gonna
have to deal with terrain and it deals
with grass and and paved roads and dirt
roads and so on and maybe I want the
robot to stay to avoid the grass and
protect it so I have to write down a
reward function for that the robot
doesn't actually know what's grass and
what's dirt and so on
and so all it has is some sensor input
let's say lidar came from camera images
and so the first thing I'll do is I'll
write down some classifiers some
detectors for this terrain types and
then I'll define my reward function that
says you know grass is bad going on dirt
or pavement is better and so I deployed
the robot after some testing and does
well in CMU I send to Berkeley does well
in Berkeley and then I don't know I send
it to Hawaii and then Hawaii right
there's grass there's dirt but there's
maybe some dangerous surfaces as well
that I don't want the robot to go over
for dramatic effect in this talk we'll
refer to these as lava right there's
mountains of lava now what the robot
will do a deployment time is it's gonna
use a three word function that I define
to evaluate the different surfaces and
who knows what it's gonna do for lava
that wasn't right and we don't have
detectors for that we totally forgot
about it so this is one thing that can
another thing that can go wrong which is
maybe we don't actually think of all the
edge cases of all the possible things
that our robots might have to face like
dangerous surfaces that don't appear at
training time but if you're at test time
so even though with the boat example and
this navigation example there are
different things that are going wrong
they have one important thing in common
which is what gives me hope and that one
thing that they have in common is that
the designer actually did a pretty good
job for the training environments in
other words there's not much that we
know about the true reward what the
person actually wants but there's one
thing that we know which is that
whatever reward function the person
specified it might not work always it
might not produce the right behavior
always but on the training environments
it produces the right behavior and
that's information that we now have
about the true reward all right we don't
have the true reward but we know this
much and in fact that adequate that's
all that we should assume if a person
specifies a reward another way of saying
the same thing is that look what we end
up specifying is contextualized in the
experiences that we have robots are not
interpreted literally right should
interpret it as B
contextualized in the experiences that
we have for robot assistant the artist
mathematically the way we do this is
instead of just optimizing the reward
function we treat it as an observation
and the Bayesian sense about the
underlying true reward and to do that we
have to reason about if theta star is
the true reward if the trade the person
is looking at the training environment
what will they write down what is likely
for them to specify and that's where we
use our insight what we do is we say
well how likely is theta tilde to be
written down as the specified reward
well I have to look at what behavior it
incentivizes on the training
environments and if that behavior is
good with respect to theta star then I
know that if theta star is the correct
reward theta tilde is likely to be
written down more likely to be written
down by the designer as the specified
reward so that's how we do it
intuitively what this means is as
follows going back to the boat example
imagine that there's a plethora of
different reward functions that the
person that the person might define
right so there's all these different
features that might be relevant the
person specified theta 2 which is
maximized score that's what they picked
instead of just optimizing for score
what our robot is going to do is it's
going to take a step back and say what's
the experience that they had to draw on
when they specify theta 2 let's take a
look right they looked at these
environments where you could either win
with a lot of points or lose with fewer
points and theta 2 incentivizes the
behavior where you get a lot of score
and you'll and you also win and so what
the robot is wondering now is for which
of all these possibilities is winning
with high score a good idea which of
these reward functions could have been
the true reward function and what you
can figure out pretty easily is that
maximizing score likes this behavior
minimizing score or trying to lose if
that were the objective that doesn't
like this behavior so can throw that
right out but you also understand that
maximizing winning is something that
likes this behavior so now the robot
knows ok I was told to optimize for
score
I'm pretty sure the person didn't mean
to lose or to minimize score but I don't
know if they didn't mean to win because
based on the information that they had
winning also might look like a good
thing so and and they might have not
gotten that so this is a very simple to
example we've been playing with
situations that are actually complicated
where the robot doesn't get convenient
access to all the important relevant
features like winning we've been looking
at motion planning to where we end up
with is more robust behaviors and these
complicated new environments that the
robot is choosing and so overall I think
that was just one example of the
approaches we can take but overall what
I'd say is whether it's a designer
that's writing down a reward function or
an end user telling you that you're
doing something wrong or even actually
giving you Corrections what the robot
should be doing is taking all of this in
as useful evidence it's useful
information about what people actually
want and what the robot is actually
supposed to do and improving that over
time and getting better and better at
optimizing not a specified reward but
what people actually want here's what
happens with our little example when you
do this I push on the robot and instead
of just going back the robot interprets
that as evidence about what I want and
it ends up doing the task very
differently so to conclude there's this
mismatch that we now have and I think
both making robots more trustworthy and
the ways that we've talked about as well
as making robots more transparent it's
going to help with not necessarily
resolving one thing or another but
bringing these these two items the real
robot and the mental model closer to
each other and have a common middle
ground that works out well for the human
and the robot with that I'd like to
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you so much you won't need the mic
so that was really wonderful and I think
especially the ways in which you focused
on reward functions as connected
directly into the end of the previous
panel this idea that we want the robots
to to support our goals in our interests
well then we have to say what counts as
success and how do we do that well that
might be very hard for us humans to do
and so how can the robot learn what we
wanted without us even knowing it but
but of course I have to ask that there's
a risk I might say and want the robot to
help me not eat lots of chocolate cake
but then it looks at what I actually do
and says you eat a lot of chocolate cake
so how do we help the you know are there
ways that the robots might be able to
help us overcome our own in abilities to
live by what we want that's a fantastic
question because I think you're right
that there is there is a risk that what
we end up optimizing for and what we
want the robot to do are very different
but maybe one way I'd look at this is
that our objectives are still there is
to want to be a healthy person but I'm
pretty let's say myopic or greedy in my
planning horizon right so I end up being
tempted by the chocolate because I don't
necessarily think through in the moment
of all the implications this is gonna
have or maybe I'm just you know there's
one there's many ways to which I can be
suboptimal and what I'm going for and so
I think one important sort of line of
work to take when trying to look at
human behavior and sort of back out what
our incentives are is is to account for
the fact that people are not gonna be
optimal and serve therefore their
Corrections and their actions are not
necessarily gonna be what they would if
the person were actually truly optimal
perfectly optimal and what we've been
finding is that for instance if we
assume that the person
myopic right then we can do a much
better job recovering their true
objective function and sort of kind of
controlled experiments then if we assume
that they weren't right so I think it's
important for robots to actually take
these biases that we might have and
they're different ones they're just
planning fallacy there's all sorts of
different biases that people have but
but maybe that's one way to think about
it and that would enable the robot not
necessarily to identify what do we want
to be healthy or not but I think the key
to what I was talking about is really
get the right uncertainty right it's not
like the robot knows whether they're
winning or score is the right one it's
not like the robot knows that lava is
bad right it just knows that given what
you've said there's not enough evidence
of either way and it has uncertainty
about those and there's there's things
that it doesn't have uncertainty about
because they don't match up at all it's
not they're not possible hypotheses
being able to recognize some of those
known unknowns I mean something become a
known unknown to use the language from
America's talk that's tonight so I
wonder could you also use these same
sorts of techniques to handle potential
challenges where the robot has to
interact with multiple people so the
robot has to learn you know interacts
with you interacts with me and we might
have different reward functions where it
has to learn what's in common what's
different between us with the same kind
of techniques be usable for that
challenge good so one thing that we've
experimented with is if the robot can
learn from many people when it sees a
new person it shouldn't start from
scratch right so for instance we did
this in the context of say driving
styles right so I want the car to
customize to how you want to drive how
they want to drive how they want to
drive and when I see the end person I
don't want to start there sort of
learning from scratch because there's
common things that all people share and
then there's individual differences and
so one way I think about this is to
learn from your from all of your
previous users and build in a sense of
prior for for what you should expect
going in and then let that new person's
actions sort of and take those in as
evidence and turn that driver into a
voice
so can thereby sort of find what's
similar among all of us while still
allowing for the fact that people do
drive differently or want the robot arm
to move differently the kind of
individual customization that's right
that's right
but I do want to bring up a related
point that I struggle with which is the
car has multiple passengers which
driving style should I choose I put a
robot in a home and there's different
people who all have different
preferences which of them write what
combination I think all the tools that I
was talking about and all everything
that I've done has been very much along
the line of one one person one robot and
the robot is trying to learn these sort
of the internal objective that the
person wants the robot to be optimizing
and I don't know what to do when there's
multiple people I mean there's simple
things you could do like you could take
averages you could do sort of risk
averse you could do min max you could do
max min there's things like that but I
don't know what the right answer is well
I think in fairness to you
I don't think social scientists know I
don't think political scientists know I
mean this is sort of the ubiquity
ubiquitous problem in human experiences
what do you have when you're conflicting
values and conflicting interests I think
it's okay if robot assists haven't
solved this problem for us yet but we'll
look forward to it in a few years and I
guess speaking of a few years I'm
curious what do you see is sort of the
biggest opportunities for trust AI
robotics sort of in this space over the
next let's say five to ten years I think
I'm gonna go with basically Eli's answer
because I feel like as AI capability
advances and I'm much more pessimistic
about the degree of that advanced than
other people are but I think we are
making progress I think with that we get
this opportunity to help people be
better at the things that they do so you
know kind of talking about what we were
saying earlier where people tend to be
myopic well one thing that we found is
that it when the robot is on the same
team with you and you're trying to do it
together if the robot acknowledges that
you maybe don't tend to think ten steps
ahead it can sort of organize the world
and take actions in such a way that when
you then react to those actions that
reaction is good globally as well simple
example because I think what I'm saying
is very abstract it can be as simple as
when I give when the robot gives you an
object okay take it okay you take it in
the most comfortable way for you now
imagine you had an actual goal like you
have to put in a dishwasher or something
right we don't tend to necessarily think
ahead to the goal
we just we do the thing right not always
and not for everyone but especially if
we're wrapped up with other things and
one thing that the robot could do is can
be reasoning about that and then he and
you the thing sort of in a way where it
makes sure that the way you then grab it
is then conducive to your goal so use
things you still react myopically but
the robot is setting things up such that
you're actually better at the task
because of its actions or another thing
is going back to explain ability it'd be
nice and I think people are doing that
because robots are getting better and
better things like go and so on and
whatever other tasks better than human
capability it'd be nice if that made us
better as well so robot could kind of
help you make these decisions and say if
you do this just be careful that you
know 10 moves from now you might end up
here and here's why and then the person
can learn from that
and get better and so so just to
conclude the more speculative question
so in say 10 years when we're on I guess
that would be the sixth CMU K&L gates
conference how is it going to be
different how do you think things are
going to have changed either socially or
in this that we're talking about here
I guess my prediction would be that
we're gonna start talking even more
about what I might call model Mis
specification so that's one thing that I
kind of foresee being very worried about
because so what do you mean by that
right
so we talked a lot about trying to
figure out what people want and I'm
worried that oftentimes the space that
we're we're always looking at a kind of
a closed world assumption here are the
possible things even if they're defined
on sort of raw information you're the
possible things that a person could want
and I just worried that we don't have
even observations about things that
people care about that influence what
they want and so kind of model Mis
specification drawing these inferences
over a closed world when we just we in
fact have no way of knowing basically
leads to lead can lead to issues another
thing they can lead to issue is just
inherent ambiguity where I really can't
figure out based on what you're doing or
what you're saying if you want this or
better that so then I'm sort of I need
to be risking risk-averse or
conservative but that's the best I can
do the other thing that I think will
change is is maybe the hype for AI will
die down and will get welcome to focus
much more on these very kind of I don't
know near-term very practical ethical
issues and I think this particular
conference is a really good job with
that but I've been at kind of other
types of events where it's you know it's
sort of very far out that everyone's
worried that in 10 years artificial
general intelligence will happen and I
think my prediction is that you know it
won't and then the hype will be a little
more reduced then we'll be able to talk
about real kind of what yellow is saying
you know real kind of narrow AI that
does something really useful which can
both empower and and cause challenges
for people that's right
well thank you so much this is really
wonderful
and this this concludes our session on
trust I invite you all to stay and have
lunch in the back room please feel free
to come back up to these tables it's
perfectly fine to have food and beverage
here and we will be starting back up at
noon with our session on policy and
governance Thanks